tick tock with its viral dance routines
and political activism videos
is a favorite among teenagers worldwide
but with more than 2 billion downloads
and 17 billion dollars in revenue last
year
the app is extremely successful and
influential
but its exploding popularity has also
raised red flags
in the u.s officials are investigating
whether tick-tock is a threat to
national security
there are concerns that the data
collected by the app owned by the
chinese firm bite dance
could be accessed by beijing the company
denies any connection with the chinese
government
but donald trump is threatening to ban
the app in the us
we're looking at tick-tock we may be
banning tick-tock we may be doing
some other things or a couple of options
but a lot of things are happening so
we'll see what happens but
we are looking at a lot of alternatives
with respect to tick-tock
one of those alternatives is for bite
dance to give up its ownership of the
app
potential buyers are reportedly already
in talks to take over
including tech giant microsoft
in the face of presidential threats tick
us assures its influencers and audience
that this is not the end we've heard
your outpouring of support and we want
to say
thank you we're not planning on going
anywhere
tick tock is a home for creators and
artists to express themselves their
ideas
and connect with people across different
backgrounds and we are so proud
of all the various communities that call
tick-tock their home
it's not clear if president trump
actually has the executive power to ban
the app in the u.s
but a national security review of tick
tock is expected to be presented to him
in the coming days
and joining me from san francisco is ina
freed she's the chief
technology correspondent for axios hi
ina thanks for joining us
so we heard the head of tiktok usa there
say we're not going anywhere
how much of that is an empty promise
well it's certainly not entirely in tick
tock's hands that's what they hope
and there's reason to think that a deal
should be able to be reached but that
doesn't mean that in this administration
it will happen uh who knows with donald
trump uh
what exactly his issue is and what will
state it what will solve the issue for
trump now we've heard reports that
microsoft
plans to buy tick tock or at least
they're in talks to do that
the u.s operations anyway um would that
put an end to the security concerns that
the
u.s government has well i would have
thought so
but um the administration has indicated
in the last 24 hours that it doesn't
solve their concerns so i'm not really
sure what their concerns
are that a deal wouldn't solve but
microsoft
has apparently and tick tock have been
in talks they thought they had a deal
they thought they had a deal that would
please the white house
with bite dance selling all of its stake
perhaps some of its non-china investors
remaining investors
and microsoft taking over which would
seem to solve the security issues
um but that doesn't appear to be enough
so it's unclear
what the trump administration wants it's
unclear
what their main issue is since if it's a
national security issue
wouldn't microsoft owning it solve that
it's it's really
puzzling to be honest and i've covered
tech for 20 years
okay so despite the fact that it's not
exactly clear what they want what
are the basic concerns that they have
with tick tock in its current form
well i think there's up to three
concerns the the one that's being voiced
is the national con
security concern that data of americans
could end up in chinese hands
the two other things that are at play
here that don't get talked about are
the broader trade war with china
certainly
uh the us and china are at a low when it
comes to
relations and there's a lot of threats
going back and forth
about companies and then the third is
donald trump had a rally in tulsa
and a bunch of popular tick tock users
managed to
get free tickets so that the trump
campaign thought they had the rally
sold out and in fact it was uh pranked
if you will
and that may be weighing on the
president's mind it may not but that's
certainly an issue
underneath the covers now it's clear
that this is still speculation at this
point but what would that mean for users
of the app and there's millions of them
if it was banned would it just disappear
from their phones like what would that
look like
well it's really interesting i mean you
know in theory uh the administration
could use emergency economic powers to
stop uh the app from being legally
distributed so probably
at a minimum would stop new people from
downloading it
um it's not clear whether they would
force it also
off off the air if you will um and then
you might see users turn to vpns because
it would still be in lots of other
countries
you might see some of those creators go
to other services
which would seemingly play into the
hands of facebook which just last week
was the subject of antitrust hearings
we've seen that facebook is also
interested in uh duplicating other apps
what it did to snapchat
um and now instagram is trying to
duplicate some of the features
uh of of um this app
so could you foresee that there would be
an alternative out there and that this
might be one of the goals here
for sure i mean you know if tick-tock
actually does get banned i think you
will see i mean
the teens aren't going to suddenly shut
their phones and and go do something
else so
they're going to go somewhere it could
be to a facebook-owned rival
it could be to a new startup
inna freed chief tech correspondent with
axios in san francisco thank you
thanks
you